- We are back and so far this hour,
we've unveiled never
before seen interviews
with couples and co-stars,
but some siblings are truly
perfect pairs as well,
especially Ron and Clint Howard.
While they were here, Clint
shared a certain passion
that I'm totally into, as you'll see.
So Clint, I heard you also
have an unusual hobby,
and I love this,
'cause I actually was
obsessed with snow globes
when I was a kid.
I don't know why, and I still love them.
I think they're magical and I
try to get my kids into them.
But you love snow globes, you make them.
- Yes, I do.
I make one-offs from scratch.
- That's amazing.
So, I don't even know how you
would go about doing that,
I feel like you should come
back for a demo on that,
'cause I've never done that.
But are you a fan of snow
globes, are you into them?
- I'm a particular fan of his snow globes
because they're so inventive.
They're a work of art really.
They're eccentric, they're kooky.
- [Kelly] Yeah, best kind.
- Maybe he uses his Ice Cream Man voice
while he's making them.
I don't know what trance he goes into.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I
just, I'll have nightmares.
- But some of them are pretty weird,
and some of them are very heartwarming,
but they're all totally originally
and honestly, they
really are works of art.
- Okay, well I think that
this picture that I found
goes actually, this is the best way
to sell your snow globes.
I think this captures the
essence of snow globes.
Right here.
This is actually
(audience laughing)
I mean, this is, people
this is marketing at its finest.
- Yeah, you're really helping
to sell our book here.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
Your family-friendly book.
- [Clint] Thank God for that Elvis.
- It takes all kinds of
boys to make a family.
See what I'm saying?
But I love, is this, it reminded me.
Is this of Burt Reynolds, back in the day
when he did that centerfold thing?
I actually saw that and I was like,
oh my God, it looks like
the Burt Reynolds thing
and they were like,
I think he did a play off of that.
Is that what it was?
- Well, Burt Reynolds
was friends with Dad.
Burt Reynolds did an episode
- Oh, your family as so
different from mine, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Burt did an episode of "Gentle Ben"
so he's always been in my consciousness.
Not the idea that I wanna
lay naked around snow globes,
but I was putting
together a Christmas card
and I felt like--
- Oh my god, it was a
Christmas card. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- My brother.
- I love it!
You know what, we would
get along well, Clint.
- Well, I was just trying
to take a photo of the snow globes.
- Yeah.
- And I thought it's missing something.
- (laughs) My naked body.
- So, dropped drawer
and jumped into the shot
and I got myself a winner to the point
where when I posted it on Facebook,
I was immediately put in
24-hour probationary jail
(Kelly laughing)
(audience clapping)
by Facebook.
I swear.
- [Kelly] It takes all kinds.
- They were debating whether
it was pornography or not.